Today we're going to take up the discussion where we left it last time.
We were talking about two main positions with regard to the question,
what is a person?
I'm the one hand we have the dualist view.
That's the view that we spent a fair bit of time sketching.
Uh,
last meeting.
The dualist view according to which a person is a body and a soul or perhaps
strictly speaking,
what we should say is the only part that's essential to the person is the soul.
Though it's got a rather intimate connection to a particular body.
Uh,
that's the dualist view.
And in contrast to that,
we've got the physical list view according to which,
uh,
there are just bodies.
A person is just a body as we might put it.
Now,
the crucial point here,
the point that I was turning to as we ended last time is that at all a person on
the physicalist view is just a body.
A person isn't just any old body.
A person is our body that can do a certain array of it has a certain set of
abilities,
can do a certain array of activities.
People are bodies that can think,
that can communicate,
that are rational,
that can plan,
that can feel things that can be creative and so forth and so on.
Now we might argue about what's the exact best list of those abilities for our
purposes.
I think that won't be crucial and so I'll sometimes talk about this set of
abilities without actually having a canonical list.
You know,
just think of them as the set of abilities that people have.
The things that we can do that well.
Other physical objects,
you know,
chalk radios,
cars,
those things can't do call those the the abilities that make something a person.
In fact,
to just introduce a piece of jargon,
we could call those the p abilities p for person or we could talk about the
various kinds of ways.
This is the physical way of thinking about it.
According to the physical is the person who's just a body that has the ability
to fulfill the various p functions and we can talk then about a person as a p
functioning body.
Or we could say that a person is a body that is p functioning.
It's important to see that the idea is,
although it's a body,
it's not just any old body and indeed it's not just any old human body.
After all,
you rip out your gun,
shoot me in the heart.
I bleed to death while we still have a human body in front of us,
but we don't have a p functioning body.
We don't have a body that's able to think a body that's able to plan,
to communicate,
to be creative,
to have goals,
you know?
So the crucial thing about having a person is having a p functioning body.
Now,
what's a mind on this view?
I'm the physical list view,
which it's still perfectly legitimate to talk about mines.
The point though is that from the physicalist perspective,
the best thing to say is talk about a mind is a way of talking about these
various mental abilities of the body away we nominalize it,
we talk about it using the noun,
the mind,
but talk of the mind is just a way of talking about these abilities that the
body has when it's functioning properly.
This is similar,
let's say to talking about a smile,
right?
Well,
you know,
we will eat it.
There are smiles.
Physical lists don't deny that there are mines just like we don't deny.
We all believe that there are smiles.
But what is a smile?
A smile is just a way of talking about the ability of the body to do something.
You know,
this characteristic thing we do with our lips,
exposing our teeth and so forth.
Him,
eh,
there's a smile whether dorky smile,
but there's a smile.
Now,
if you were listing the parts of the body,
you know,
you would list the teeth,
you would list the lips,
you would list the gums,
you would list the tongue,
but you wouldn't list the smile.
So you know,
should we conclude as dualists that whoa smiles are these extra nonphysical
things.
You know,
that,
that have a special intimate relationship with bodies.
Well,
you could imagine if you like that,
but when you rather a silly view talking of a smile,
talk about a smile is just a way of talking about the body's ability to smile.
There is no extra part,
even though we have a noun,
thus smile that you know,
if you're not careful,
my low you into thinking there must be a thing.
Thus smile and then you'd have all these metaphysical conundrums.
Where is the smile located?
Well,
it seems to be in the vicinity of the mouth.
Right,
but,
but you know,
but the smile isn't the lips.
The smile isn't the teeth,
you know,
so it must be something nonphysical.
No,
that would just be,
you know,
a silly way to think about smiles talk a smiles is just a way of talking about
the ability of this,
of the body to smile,
to form a smile.
That's an ability that we have our bodies have.
Similarly then according to the physicalist talk of the mind,
despite the fact that we have a noun,
there is just a way of talking about the abilities of the body to do various
things.
The the is just a way of talking about the fact that our body can think,
can communicate,
can plan,
can,
can deliberate,
can be creative,
can write poetry,
can,
can fall in love.
Talk of all of those things is what we mean by the mind,
but there's no extra thing.
The mind above and beyond the body.
That's the physical list view.
So it's important in particular to understand that from the physicalist point of
view,
the mind is not the brain,
right?
You might think,
look,
according to physical lists,
minds are just brains and that'd be it.
You know,
that wouldn't be on a horrendously misleading thing to say because according to
the best science that we've got,
the the brain is the part of the body that sort of is the seat or house or the,
you know,
the underlying mechanical structure that gives us these various abilities.
These p functions are functions that we have by virtue of our brain.
So that might tempt you into saying the mind on the physicalist view is just a
brain.
But we probably shouldn't say that because after all,
you know,
you shoot me,
there's my corpse line on the stage.
Well,
there's my brain,
you know,
my brain is still there in my head,
but we no longer have a person.
The person has died.
The person that seems,
you know,
no longer exists,
whether strictly that's the best thing to say or not as a question we'll have to
come to in a couple of weeks.
But you know,
it seems pretty clear that the mind has been destroyed even though the brain is
still there.
So I think at least when we're,
when there's the need to be careful,
maybe we don't normally have the need to be careful,
but when there's the need to be careful,
we should say talk of the mind is the way is a way of talking about the p
functioning of the body and our,
and our best science suggests that a well functioning body can perform these
things,
can think and plan and fall in love by virtue of the fact that the brain is
functioning properly.
All right,
that's the physicalist view.
Now,
if we take this,
do you know,
we thought,
look,
I'm the,
I'm the dualist view.
What was death?
Death is presumably the separation of the mind and the body with the destruction
of the,
perhaps the permanent separation with the destruction of the body.
What's death on the physicalist view or there is no extra entity.
The soul,
the mind is just the proper functioning of the body,
so the mind gets destroyed when the ability of the body to function in that way
has been destroyed.
Death is roughly the end of this set of functioning.
Again,
this probably should be cleaned up and in a couple of weeks we'll spend a day or
half period trying to clean it up and make it somewhat more precise,
but there's nothing mysterious about death from the physical list point of view,
at least about the basic idea of what's going on in death and I've got a stereo,
I suppose I hold up my boombox for you and it's playing music.
It's one of the things that can do and I drop it on the ground,
smashing it well,
no longer can function properly.
Yeah,
it's broken.
It's no mystery why it can't function once it's Grocon death is basically just
the breaking down of the body on the physicalist point of view so that it no
longer functions properly.
One other point worth emphasizing and sketching the physical list views this.
So as I said,
physical lists don't deny that there are minds,
you know,
even though we say we're just bodies,
that doesn't mean that we're just any old body.
It's not as though the physicalist view is we're bodies that you know,
have some illusion of thinking.
No,
we're bodies that really do think so.
The really our minds,
we could on the physicalist point of view,
call those souls just like there's no danger in talking of a mine from the
physical list perspective,
there wouldn't be any serious danger and talking about a soul.
And so in certain contexts I'm perfectly comfortable and my physical,
his moods,
I'm perfectly comfortable talking about,
you know,
this person's soul,
he's got a good soul,
a bad solo,
how the sole source when I read Shakespeare or what have you,
that there's nothing upsetting or improper about the language of the soul,
even on the physical,
his point of view.
But in this class,
just to try to keep us from getting confused.
As I indicated before.
Now I want to remind you,
I'm going to save the word soul when I always try to save the word soul for when
I'm talking about the dualist view.
So we might put it this way.
The neutral term is going to be mined.
We all agree that people have mine's sort of the house or the seed of our
personalities.
Uh,
and the question is what is a mind and the dual,
his position is that the mind is a soul and the soul is an immaterial object.
So when I use the word soul,
I will try to reserve it for the metaphysical view according to which souls are
something immaterial.
In contrast to that,
we've got the physical list view.
Physical assault also believe in mines,
but minds are just a way of talking about the abilities of the body.
And so they do not believe physical lists do not believe in any,
in material object above and beyond the body.
That's part of a person.
And so just to keep things clear,
I will say that physical lists,
materialists do not believe in souls because for the purposes of this class,
I'm going to reserve the word soul for the immaterialist conception of the mind
though in other contexts,
no,
no harm in talking about souls.
All right,
so,
so this is the,
these are the two basic positions,
the dualist view on the one hand,
the physical list view on the other.
And the question we need to turn to,
I take it that just as the dualist view is a familiar one.
So the,
so it's true that the physical,
his view is that it's a familiar one.
You know whether or not you believe it,
you are familiar with the fact that you know,
some people believe it or at least you wonder whether it's true.
Does science or choir that we believe in the physical list view or not.
The question we want to turn to then is,
which of these two views should we believe the dualist position or the physical
list position?
And the crucial question presumably is,
well,
should we believe in the existence of a soul?
I mean both sides believe in bodies,
right?
As I say,
the,
the dual list position is we're understanding it is not a view that says there
are only minds.
There are no bodies dualist belief that through our bodies they believe that our
souls as well as bodies physical believe that our bodies,
but no souls.
So there's an agreement that there are bodies.
No.
Here's one.
You know,
each one of you is sort of dragging one around with you.
There's agreement that there was bodies.
The question is,
are there anything beyond bodies?
Is there anything beyond the body?
Is there a soul?
Are their souls?
So that's the question that's going to concern us for a couple of weeks.
Well,
if we asked ourselves,
no,
what reasons do we have to believe in a soul?
We might start by asking what reasons do we have to believe in anything?
How do we prove the existence of things?
Now,
for lots of familiar every day objects,
the answer is fairly straight forward.
We prove their existence by using our five senses.
We just see them,
right?
How do I know that there are chairs?
Well,
you know,
there are some chairs in front of me,
opened my eyes.
I see them.
How do I know that there is a lectern?
Well,
I,
I see it.
I can touch it.
I feel it.
How do I know that there are trees?
I see them.
How do I know that there are birds?
I see them,
I hear them.
How do I know that there are apples?
I see them,
I taste them.
So forth and so on.
But that approach pretty clearly isn't going to work for souls because a soul,
and again,
we got in mind this metaphysical view corn,
which is something immaterial isn't something we see.
It's not something we taste or touch or smell or hear.
We don't directly observe souls with our five senses.
Might wonder,
well why don't I sort of directly observe it in myself that I have a soul.
And although I guess there have been people who've,
who've made that sort of claim,
it's seems false to me.
I can only ask each of you to sort of introspect for a second,
you know,
so turn your mind's eye inward and ask,
do you see a soul inside you?
I don't think so.
I mean,
I,
I see no things outside me.
I feel certain sensations in my body,
but it doesn't seem as though I observe a soul.
Even if I believe in a soul,
I don't see it.
Well,
how do we prove the existence of things we can't see or hear or taste and so
forth.
The,
the usual method,
maybe not the only method,
but the usual method is something like this.
Sometimes we posit the existence of something that we can't see,
so as to explain something else that we all agree takes place.
Okay.
Why do I believe in the existence of atoms?
I don't see individual atoms.
Why do I believe in the existence of atoms so small that I can't see them?
Because atomic theory explains things when I pause it.
The existence of atoms with certain structures and certain sort of ways of
interacting and combine it and building up.
When I pause it,
Adam's suddenly I can explain all sorts of things about the physical world and
so I infer the existence of atoms.
Okay.
Based on the fact that doing that allows me to explain things that need
explaining.
This is a kind of argument that we use all the time.
Yeah.
How do I pause it?
You know why?
Why do I believe in X-ray's even though I don't see them?
Because doing that allows me to explain certain things.
Why do I believe in,
you know,
certain planets,
you know too far away to be observed directly through a telescope?
Because positing them allows you to explain certain things about the rotation of
the star,
the gravitational fluctuations,
what have you.
We make inferences to the existence of things we can't see when doing that helps
us to explain something we can't otherwise explain.
This pattern of argument,
which is ubiquitous is called inference to the best explanation.
Now I want to emphasize this bit about best explanation.
What we're justified in believing are those things that we need,
not simply when they would offer us some kind of explanation,
but when they offer us the best explanation that we can think of.
So look,
why am I justified in believing in germs,
various kinds of viruses that I can't see because of bacteria?
What have you.
Because doing that allows me to explain why people get sick.
Oh,
but there's other things that would allow me to explain that as well.
How about demons?
Alright,
I could believe in demons and say,
Oh,
you know,
why did the person gets sick and die?
We're all,
you know,
it was demonic possession.
Why are anti justified in believing in the existence of demons?
It's a possible explanation.
But what we've seen to be justified in believing,
it's not just any old explanation,
but the best explanation.
So we've got two rival explanations.
We've got roughly germ theory and we've got demon theory and we'd have to ask
ourselves,
which of these does a better job of explaining the facts about disease?
Who gets what kinds of diseases,
how diseases spread,
how they can be treated or cured.
When they kill somebody.
And the fact of the matter is demon theory doesn't do a very good job of
explaining disease where wild germ theory does do a good job.
It's the better explanation.
And so we're justified in believing in germs but not demons.
So it's a matter of inference not just to any old explanation,
but inference to the best explanation.
All right,
so what we need to ask ourselves then is,
what about the soul can't observe souls,
but here's a possible way of arguing for them.
Are there things that need to be explained that we could explain?
If we posited the existence of a soul and immaterial object above and beyond the
body,
are there things that the existence of the soul could explain
and explained better?
Then the explanation that we would have if we had to limit ourselves to bodies?
My put it this way,
there's sort of the easiest version of this kind of argument for our purposes.
Are there things about us that the physicalist cannot explain?
Are there mysteries or puzzles about people that the physical is just draws a
blank?
But if we become lists,
we could explain these features.
Suppose there was a feature like that feature f,
then we'd say,
look,
although we can't see the soul,
we have reason to believe in the soul because positing the existence of a soul
helps us to explain the existence of feature F,
which we all agree.
We've got.
Suppose it was true that you couldn't explain love from the physicalist
perspective,
but we all know that people do fall in love,
but souls would allow us to explain that.
Well,
boom,
we'd have an argument for the existence of a soul.
It would be an example of inference to the best explanation.
Now the,
the crucial question of course is what's the relevant feature?
F Yep.
Is there some feature that the physicalist can't explain?
And so we need to appeal to something extra physical to explain it.
Or The physical list can only do a rotten job of explaining.
And if we were to repeat like,
like demon theory did you know if we have appeal to something nonphysical,
we do a better job of explaining
if we could find the right eth and make off the argument.
The physicalist can't explain it or does a bad job of explaining it and the
dualist does a better job of explaining it.
We'd have reason to believe in the soul,
like all arguments in philosophy.
It would be a tentative argument.
It would be.
It would we,
we,
we sort of have some reason to believe in the soul until we sort of see what's
next.
Argument comes down the road.
But at least it would give us some reason to believe in the soul.
So what I want to do is ask what might feature F B
is there any such feature f and it's probably also worth underlining the fact
that what I'm really then doing is running through a series of arguments.
Inference to the best explanation is not a single argument for the soul.
It's rather the name for a kind of argument.
And depending on what f you fill in the blank with,
you know,
what pet feature or fat you're trying to explain by appeal to the soul,
you get a different argument.
All right,
so let's ask ourselves,
are there things that we need to appeal to the soul in order to,
to in order to explain these things about us?
Well,
here's a first try.
Actually let me start by saying I'm going to distinguish two broad families of,
of characteristics we might appeal to that might,
we might say one set of approaches focus on ordinary familiar every day facts
about us.
The fact that we love the fact that we think the fact that uh,
you know,
we experience emotions,
what have you,
these just sort of ordinary features of us.
And then I'm going to start with those and then I'll turn eventually to another
set of possible things that might need explaining,
which we might think of as extra ordinary supernatural things.
You know,
maybe there are certain supernatural things about communication from the,
from the dead or near death experiences that need to be explained in terms of
the soul.
So,
so we'll get to those,
but we'll start with sort of ordinary everyday humdrum facts about us.
Even though they're ordinary and familiar,
it still could turn out that we need to appeal to souls in order to explain
them.
So to start,
how about this,
start with the familiar faculty have already drawn your attention to a couple of
times that you know,
you could have a body that's dead.
You know,
you can have a corpse and that's clearly not a person.
It's not a living being.
It's not a person,
it doesn't do anything.
It just lies there.
Whereas your body,
my body is animated,
right?
I'm,
I move my hands around,
my mouth is going up and down.
It walks from one part of the stage to the other part of the stage.
Maybe we need the to appeal to the soul in order to explain sort of what
animates the body.
And the thought would be,
you know,
when the soul and the body had been separated,
that's the dual list explains the soul has lost its ability to give commands to
the body.
And so the body's no longer animated.
So we've got a possible explanation of the difference between an animated and an
on animated or inanimate body to it is the soul in contact of the right sort
with the body.
There's a possible explanation.
Might say,
look,
the physicalist can't tell us that because all the physical parts are still
there.
When you've got the corpse Elise,
if it's all a fresh corpse before the decay has set in.
So we need to appeal to the existence of a soul in order to explain the
animation of bodies.
Like you know,
the ones that you and I have.
Well,
I said I was going to run through a series of arguments,
but that doesn't mean it doesn't mean that,
uh,
that license just turned off.
I don't know why.
It doesn't mean that the,
okay
[inaudible] it doesn't mean that I think the arguments all work right now.
I had noticed on the first day of class that I don't myself believe in the
existence of a soul.
And as such,
it shouldn't be any surprise to you that what I'm going to do as we run through
each of these arguments and say,
I'm not convinced by it,
and here's why.
Now,
since since I think that the argument I'm about to sketch and I just started
sketching,
the first off is fails.
No,
I hope you'll,
you'll think it over and you'll eventually come to agree with me.
Yeah.
These arguments don't really work after all,
but what's more important to me is that you at least think about each of these
arguments.
Is this a convincing argument for the existence of a soul?
If,
if,
if you think so,
what response do you want to offer to the objections that I'm giving?
If this argument doesn't work,
is there another argument for the existence of a soul that you think's a better
one?
All right,
so first argument,
you need the sold order to explain the animation of the body from the physical,
his point of view.
Of course the answer's going to be too quick
to have an animated body.
You need to have a functioning body.
And it's true that when you got a corpse,
you got all the parts there,
but clearly they're not functioning properly.
But all that shows us is the parts have broken.
Remember my stereo,
I dropped my stereo,
it falls on the stage.
It doesn't work anymore.
It stops giving off music.
My boombox stops giving off music.
That's not because previously,
you know,
we had a,
we had a CD inside of it.
We have some batteries.
We dropped the whole thing.
It's not as though previously there was something nonmaterial there.
You've got all the same parts there,
but the parts are now broken.
They're not connected to each other in the right way.
The energy is not flowing from the batteries,
uh,
through of the wires to the CD component.
There's nothing mysterious from the physicalist perspective about the idea that
a physical object can break.
And so although we need to offer a story about what makes the parts work when
they're connected with each other and interacting in the right way,
there's no need to appeal to anything beyond the physical.
Well,
supposedly tried to refine the argument.
Suppose we say you need to appeal to the soul in order to explain that.
Just that like the body moves around flails but the body sort of act
purposefully.
We need something sort of to be pulling the strings to be directing the body.
That's what the soul
so says the blue dualist and response.
The physicalist is going to say yes,
it's true that bodies don't just move around in random patterns.
Human bodies don't do that,
so we need something to direct it,
but why couldn't that just be one particular part of the body plays the part of
the command module.
Suppose I've got a heat seeking missile,
you know which
tracks down the the plane
as the plane tries to dodge it,
the missile corrects its course.
It's not just moving randomly.
It's moving purposefully.
The better be something that explained that's controlling the motions of the
missile,
but for all that it could just be a particular piece of the missile that does
it.
Okay.
More gloriously.
We could imagine building some kind of a robot that does a variety of tasks and
it's not moving randomly,
but the tasks for all that are controlled by the CPU within the,
the robot.
So the physicalist says we don't need to appeal to anything as extravagant as a
soul in order to explain the fact that bodies don't just move randomly,
but they move in purposeful ways and are controlled now.
No,
no.
For each objection there's a response,
right?
You could imagine the doulas coming back and saying,
look,
in that case of the heat seeking missile,
uh,
the or the robot for that matter,
although it's doing things,
it's just obeying orders and the orders were given to it from something outside
itself,
something programmed the robot or the missile.
So don't we need there to be something outside the body that programs the body
and that could be the sole,
that's a harder question.
Must there be something outside the body that controls the body?
Well,
look,
one possibility of course is,
well,
why not say that people are just robots as well?
And we get our commands from outside.
I mean,
I know familiar religious view,
God builds Adam out of dirt,
uh,
out of dust.
Adam is just a certain kind of robot.
Then God sort of breeze into Adam that sort of turning it on and gets out.
Maybe people are just command.
I would just robots commanded from outside by God.
But that doesn't mean that there's anything more to us than there is to the
robot.
That's one possible response.
Different response of course is couldn't we have robots that just build more
robots?
And then if you ask where did the command's come from the answer as well,
when they were built,
they were built in such a ways to sort of have certain instructions that they
begin to follow up,
follow out,
just like people have a genetic code perhaps that gives us various instructions
that we begin to fall out or certain innate psychology or what have you.
Well look,
we argument quickly becomes very,
very messy and,
and,
and the,
the soul of the fan of the soul begins to want to protest.
But look,
we're not just robots.
You know,
we're not just robots with some sort of program in our brain that we're
following.
We've got freewill and,
and robots can't have freewill.
And so there's gotta be something more to us than robots.
We can't just be physical things.
This is an interesting argument,
but I think it's a new argument.
So,
so we started with the idea you needed to appeal the souls in order to roughly
explain why human bodies move,
why were animated or why are we moving non random ways.
And I think it's fairly clear that you don't need to appeal the souls in order
to do that.
Appeal to a physical body suffices.
I think to have an explanation as to the difference between an animated and an
inanimate body.
How bodies will move in non random ways that,
you know,
if the brain is our CPU,
then you know,
we'll,
we'll behave in,
in deliberate purposeful ways.
Just like a robot behave,
behaving deliberate,
purposeful ways.
So this initial argument thinks not compelling
still.
We might wonder what about this new argument?
Yeah.
What about the fact that,
you know,
so we said,
look,
there's a,
there's a family of arguments,
all of which have the general structure inference to the best explanation.
You need souls in order to explain feature F,
plugging a different feature f and you get a new argument.
The one we started with,
you need the body to explain the,
the animation.
It needed the soul to explain the animation of the body that that argument I
think doesn't work.
But now we've got a new one.
You need the soul in order to explain freewill.
Let me come back to that argument later.
It's a good argument.
It's an argument well worth taking seriously,
but it's come back to it later.
First,
let's run through some other things that might be appeal to as candidates for
feature F.
Suppose somebody says,
look,
yeah,
it's true that we don't need to appeal to souls in order to explain why bodies
move around in a non random fashion.
But people have a very special ability and so the argument goes that mere bodies
couldn't have physicalist can't explain.
That's the ability to think.
It's the to reason people have beliefs and desires and based on their beliefs
about how to fulfill their desires,
they,
they plant,
they make plans,
they have strategies.
They reason about what to do.
This,
this,
this tightly connected set of facts about us,
beliefs,
desires,
reasoning,
strategizing,
planning.
You need to appeal to a soul.
So the argument goes,
you need to appeal to a soul to explain that no mere machine could believe no
mirror machine has desires.
No Mirror machine could reason.
Now it's easy to see why you might think that sort of thing.
When you stick to sort of simple machines,
it's pretty clear that there are lots of machines that it doesn't seem natural
to ascribe beliefs or desires or goals or reasoning to my lawn mower for
example,
doesn't want to cut the grass.
Um,
even though it does cut the grass,
it doesn't have the desire.
It doesn't think to itself.
How shall I get that blade that's of grass that's been alluding me.
So it's,
it's easy to see why we might be tempted to say no mere machine could think or
reason or have beliefs or desires.
But that argument is much less compelling nowadays then I think it would have
been 20 or 40 years ago in an era of computers,
it seems with,
with quite sophisticated computer programs,
it seems at least at the very least natural to talk about beliefs,
desires and reasoning and strategizing.
So I suppose for example,
we've got a chess playing computer and my computer at home,
I've got a program that allows my chest to play computer.
I myself stink at chess.
This,
uh,
this program can beat me,
you know,
blind.
So I move,
you know,
my,
my bishop,
the computer moves,
it's queen.
What do we say about the computer?
Why did the computer move it's queen or it's virtual queen.
Why did the computer move it's queen?
Well,
the natural thing to say is it's worried about the fact that the king is exposed
and it's trying to block me by capturing my bishop.
That is
what we say about computer playing programs.
Stop.
Think about what we're doing.
We're ascribing desires to the program or saying it's got an ultimate desire to
win the game.
Certain subsidiary desires to protect its king.
To capture my king certain other subsidiary desire,
no doubt to protect its various other pieces along the way.
It's got beliefs about how to do that by blocking certain paths or by exposing
make it other pieces on my side vulnerable.
It's got beliefs about how to achieve its goals and then it puts those
combinations of beliefs and desires into action by moving in a way.
That's a rational response to my move.
So it looks as though the natural thing to say about the chess playing computer
is it does have beliefs,
it does have desires,
it does have intentions,
it does have goals,
it does reason.
It does all of this.
It's rational to this limited extent,
the only able to play chess.
But to that extent it's doing all these things and yet we're not tempted to say,
are we that the computer has a nonphysical part.
We can explain how the computer does all of this in strictly physical terms.
And of course once you start thinking of it this way,
it's natural to talk this way and across of course,
of variety across a variety of things that the computer may be trying to do.
Now,
of course,
it's perfectly open to you as a dual list to respond by saying,
yeah,
although we personify the computer,
we treat it as though it was a person as no it had beliefs and desires and so
forth.
It doesn't really have the relevant beliefs and desires because it doesn't have
any beliefs and desires because no physical object could have beliefs and
desires.
And,
and in response to that,
I just want to say,
isn't that just prejudice?
Of course,
it is true that if we simply insist,
no physical object could really have beliefs or desires,
then it will follow that.
When we are tempted to ascribe beliefs and desires to my chess playing computer,
we're falling into an illusion that will follow once we assume that no physical
object has beliefs or desires.
What?
What reason is there for
saying it has no beliefs or desires?
What grounds is there for withholding a scriptions of beliefs and desires to the
computer?
That's far from obvious.
Well,
here's a possibility.
Okay.
Desires at the very least seem to be,
at least in typical cases,
very closely tied to a series of emotions.
You get excited when you're playing chess at the prospect of crack capturing my
queen and crushing me.
You get worried
when you're a pieces are threatened
and of course more generally,
you know,
you get excited when you know your heart goes pitter pat when your girlfriend or
boyfriend says they love you.
Yeah,
your stomach six,
you've got that sinking feeling in the pit of your stomach.
You know when you get a bad grade on a test,
maybe what's really going on is the thought that there's an aspect of desire
that has a purely behavioral side that's,
you know,
moving pieces around in a way that would make sense if you had this goal.
But there's an mat.
Machines can do that,
but there's an aspect of desires.
The emotional side that machines can't have,
but we clearly do have.
And maybe we want to build that emotional side into talk of desires.
So maybe if we want to say machines don't have a mental life and couldn't have a
mental life,
what we really mean is no machine could feel anything emotionally.
So let's distinguish,
let's say there's a way of talking about beliefs and desires,
which is just gone to be captured in terms of,
you know,
responding in a way that makes sense given the environment.
Right?
And maybe computers and robots could do that,
but there's clearly,
aside of our mental life,
the emotional side,
well we might really worry,
could a robot feel love?
Could it be afraid of anything?
So again,
our question was do we need to appeal the souls to explain something about
physical says no.
Doula says yes if what we need is the mental,
but that the aspect of behavioral aspect of the mental where even a chess
playing computer probably has it.
And that's not a very compelling argument.
Physicalist we'll say look,
that aspect of the mental,
it's pretty clear.
We can explain in physical terms,
but let's just switch the argument.
What about emotions?
Can a robot feel emotions?
Could a purely physical being fallen love?
Could it be afraid of things?
Could hope for something.
The,
the latest version of our argument then is people can feel emotions,
but if you think about it,
it's pretty clear.
No robot could feel emotions.
No merely physical thing could feel emotions,
and so there must be more to us than a merely physical thing.
That's the argument.
We'll start with next time.